there's nothing like some refreshing ice
cream on a hot summer's day but eat it
quick before it melts right it's been
pretty much an hour it's melted and here
is the it appears to not remoted it's
not melting why isn't it melty wrong
this is wrong so is this a frozen fake
this can't be real or is there some ice
cool chemistry going on ice cream is a
mixture of fat sugar ice crystals and
air we take ice cream out of the freezer
two things happen first heat transfers
into the ice cream which heats up the
ice and makes it melt into water the
second thing that causes ice cream to
melt is the fact that these air bubbles
start to break down so he ends up with a
puddle of ice cream now we can see this
has clearly happened with the two scoops
of ice cream
with the Ice Cream Sandwich it's
different two ingredients keep this ice
cream firm stabilizers and emulsifiers
stabilizes at compounds like gums or
long-chain sugar molecules these able to
bind to the free-flowing water that is
melted away from the ice crystals
stopping them from moving about I'm also
very low derived from vegetable fat or
egg yolk and they keep fat and water
from separating this is because an
emulsifier has two amazing ends to it
one that loves water and one that loves
fat and so it helps bind the structure
together preventing these two from
separating out forming a kind of
scaffolding structure throughout the ice
cream that traps air so though it might
seem strange that this ice cream isn't
melting it's perfectly safe to eat so it
looks like this ice cream sandwich will
melt when hell freezes over